البنيه التحتيه لوجهه مسار في مكه المكرمه
تقترب من الاكتمال وصلت نسبه الانجاز
93% بنهايه الربع الاول من العام الجاري
وتمر الوجهه التنمويه عبر عده مراحل
ابرزوا انجاز البنيه التحتيه لها خلال
العام الجاريه التي تشمل الطرق وانفاق
المشاه والجسور ومحطات المترو ومحطات
ومواقف الحافلات التردديه وتسعى ايضا وجهه
مسار الى توسعه خيارات النقل للزائرين وفق
مفهوم الحركه الشامله التي تمنع تقاطع
المركبات مع المشاه
من مشروع مسار في مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز نواف مرحبا بك
93% هو حجم الانجاز في وجهه مسار في
المرحله الاولى حدثنا اكثر عن تفاصيل في
هذه المرحله
نعم خالد البناء لا يتوقف في مشروع مسار
مكه غرب العاصمه المقدسه والمسجد الحرام
نسبه الانجاز تجاوزت
93% الاعمال الخاصه بالبناء التحتيه توشك
على الانتهاء من طرق رئيسيه هو ممرات
وايضا مواقف السيارات اتواجد الان فوق
احدى سطوح مباني مواقف السيارات كما نشاهد
الان وهي هذه المباني التي تضم
تستوعب نحو 5000
مركبه من خلال التصميم لهذه الطوابق
الخاصه بها الطابق المبنى الاول
لمواقف السيارات مكون من سبع طوابق تمتد
على طول مسار مكه بنحو اربع كيلو مترات
تدريجيا تستوعب
الزوار لمسار مكه
قاصدي المسجد الحرام العديد من الاصول
التي اصبحنا نشاهدها الان بعد اكتمال
البناء التحتيه ايضا يتوسط مسار مكه مسجد
كبير يمتد على مساحه
141 الف متر مربع وهو ياتي بالوسط هذا
بالاضافه الى
المشاريع الاخرى ضمن المسار وضمن اعمال
البنى التحتيه هو التي من اهمها حقيقه
الطرق الرئيسيه الطريق
الجنوبي وايضا الطريق الشمالي بالاضافه
الى ممر المشاه الذي نتواجد في بدايته
الان وهو الذي ينقل المشاه من والى المسجد
الحرام ويمرون بالعديد من المشاريع الكبرى
هنا ايضا خالد تتواجد مشاريع تطويريه
جاهزه وقد بدا البناء لها بالفعل من فنادق
وغيرها بالاضافه الى
الاراضي التطويريه وهي اكثر من 200 قطعه
ارض تطويريه ومخصصه للتطوير من مشاريع
فندقيه وسكنيه ايضا بالاضافه الى المشاريع
التجاريه والمرافق الصحيه سيكون هذا
المشروع خالد بعد الانتهاء والذي سيتم
افتتاحه في هذا العام بشكل تدريجي بدءا من
الطرق الرئيسيه
ومعابر المشاه مرورا بافتتاح الاصول
الكبرى للفنادق وغيرها من المهم جدا
الاشاره الى اعداد الفنادق الكبيره التي
ستفتتح في مسار مكه 23 الف غرفه فندقيه
سيتم افتتاحها في مسار مكه تبدا من ثلاث
نجوم وحتى خمس نجوم هذا ليتمكن جميع
الزوار وايضا الحجاج والمعتمرين من الحصول
السكن في هذه الفنادق بمختلف الاسعار وحسب
قدرات كل زائر او معتمر او حاج بالاضافه
الى الشقق الفندقيه التي تزيد عن 13 الف
شقه فندقيه هذا بالاضافه الى المشاريع
السكنيه الاخرى التي يبدا العمل عليها
تزامنا مع انتهاء البناء التحتيه شقق
سكنيه ايضا تتجاوز الثلاثه عشر الف الشقه
سكنيه هو 82 مبنى مخصص للسكن لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات